we're here at a state park in Malibu
California the coastline here is
beautiful in the surface legendary but
due to the state's financial crisis this
park and indeed the entire California
state park system is in peril well
California State Parks are facing some
massive challenges right now they have a
billion dollars in deferred maintenance
meaning projects that they need but they
don't have money to fund in addition
you've got the the fiscal challenges and
which have prompted the state parks to
shut or reduce services at 150 state
parks over the last year so California
State Parks like many out there are
hurting right now and they're looking
for new sources of revenue when public
agencies go looking for new sources of
revenue they typically end up calling
for an increase in taxes which is
precisely what prop 21 does prop 21
would essentially establish a new annual
$18 fee that would get tacked onto
vehicle registrations that would be
dedicated to state parks the California
residents that own the 28 million
vehicles that would be taxed would get
free entry to the state parks
essentially driving up demand at the
worst possible time for the park system
when they clearly can't accommodate the
demand they have already giving more
taxpayer money to a mismanaged park
system is no guarantee that the parts
will be saved especially if the number
of visitors increases but there's a more
fundamental problem with prop 21 I think
most people in California would say that
it's unfair to tax their vehicle which
has nothing to do with state parks to
essentially provide a subsidy for the
folks that do happen to use state parks
so what's the alternative most people
probably don't realize it but many
public parks at all levels of government
are run successfully by private sector
operators we went to Sedona Arizona and
spoke with Warren Meyer the owner of a
company called recreation resource
management we run about a hundred and
fifty parks some of those are campground
some are what we call day use areas
which is like a picnic area like here at
Crescent Moon ranch and our biggest
client is the u.s. Forest Service which
is also the largest recreation provider
public recreation provider in the world
this is not something new this is not
something untested it's happening
literally next door to many state parks
that are suffering right now
who benefits when public agencies
contract with private companies to
manage parks really everybody is a
winner in the whole thing hopefully we
make a profit which is great that's what
we're in business to do and it's an
opportunity for us but this the state
agency or the public agency is a winner
because typically they're taking
something that's a financial loser for
them a real money drain and by having us
run at a true change it from a money
drain into a financial benefit because
they're actually getting paid rent what
about the interests of park users how
for example do the parks run by meijer
company compared to the publicly run
state parks in Arizona last year three
of the public campgrounds we run were in
the top five of the rankings and none of
the top 10 were from Arizona State Parks
privately run parks are often better
managed than publicly run parks because
parks run by the government operate
within a very different incentive
structure they don't really see the user
fees they don't get to take benefit of
that a lot of that gets dumped right
into the treasury and so they don't
think of it as okay we you know if we
have more visitors as more fees which
which allows us to spend more money or
to be better on our budget they think
because they have just an expense budget
they think of every incremental visitor
as a problem as an expense a former park
ranger in California Kelly Moffett has
worked for Myers company for the past
ten years we just don't have the
restrictions that keep us caught up in
time delays that sometimes can work to
the detriment of the resource and we can
react faster and we can do so under the
supervision and the evaluating eyes of
our public partners so I think that's
the perfect relationship I've seen to
work really well okay so privately
managed parks are often better run than
publicly run parks and they generate
money for the government rather than
requiring a subsidy so why isn't there
more support for privately managed parks
one of the first things I always say is
you're going to build a McDonald's in
front of all faithful I hear that all
the time because build condos you're
going to be build a golf course if you
take a walk around these facilities
you'll see them very natural that's
because in my contracts I'm with the
tone and character the park is set by
the agency and it's my job and it's a
big part of the bid I make is I explain
to them how that I understand the tone
and character they want to maintain in
the park and express my commitment and
its expressive writing the contract
to maintain that character in fact I
can't put two boards together with a
nail without approval from the public
authority other skeptics of
public-private partnerships are worried
that a focus on the bottom line will
inevitably result in jacked up prices
there is a meeting about public parks
right here in Sedona and it was brought
up that all that you know the private
company is going to raise prices because
you know their poor profit you know the
greedy folks actually dropped fees this
year this used to be a ten-dollar
visitation here it's going to be nine
next year over at our adjacent state
park over at slide rock park they
actually the state-run facility the
state park actually raised its fees this
year from ten dollars to twenty dollars
so that's the real irony of it is the
private companies out here drop and fees
while the public agency is raising them
another concern people often have is
that private companies won't have a
sufficiently long term view that always
seems logical somehow for private
manager of parks that I'm not going to
spend any money to keep the place nice
but but my revenues are entirely
dependent on people showing up every day
stores and gas stations and everybody
else they've rejuvenate those places
every 20 years they keep them fixed up
because they want people coming back
pure in Arizona State Parks and they'll
admit it they haven't put any capital
maintenance large long-term maintenance
into their parks for years because it
has to be appropriated every year so
without that appropriation because
that's a budget football every year out
of their control you know they end up
with no capital maintenance money I on
the other hand have my budget or control
and can spend it the right way all
things considered contracting with
private companies to manage state park
seems like a winning idea but could this
kind of public-private partnership work
in California in fact Myers company
Albany does business with MacArthur
Bernie Falls State Park in Northern
California they said well we actually
have a loop of camping which will be one
circular road that has about 24
campsites on it in a bathroom they said
this is the last part of the campground
we need to refurbish and we can't afford
to do it I said well I will do it if you
allow me to operate so what I did is
actually put you know a half a million
dollars of cabins in this loop made it
more attractive to the customer and then
in return for spending that capital the
state gave me a 20-year operating lease
to run those cabins to help me get my
money back for making the investment so
what's the bottom line here
instead of imposing a sneaky new tax on
drivers in California what policymakers
should be doing is relying more on
public-private partnerships and private
recreation management companies that can
take a revenue losing state park and
actually turn it into a revenue
generating asset for the state everyone
likes parks everyone likes these natural
areas and we all like to appreciate them
it's really the difference in the way we
approach the operational and management
objectives at each park for reason TV
I'm qualify